Today we go for a hike in the Orgonian Woods and watch our back for the sound of a noisy ghost.
Was he there? Was he there?
And then we travel to Brazil to look at the story of a group of warriors who went toe-to-toe
with a one-eyed alien and then that alien started sleeping with their women today on Dead Rabbit Radio.
*music*
Hey everyone, welcome back to another episode of Dead Rabbit Radio. I'm your host Jason Carpenter. I'm having a great day.
I hope you guys are having a great day, too. We got a problem. We got a problem. It's a very interesting one.
We'll talk about that in a second. A little teaser for you.
First off, I want to give a shout out to our newest Patreon supporter, Jimmy Moore.
Jimmy Moore named after that hit Britney Spears song, "Jimmy Moore." I bet you didn't know that, Jimmy.
That's how you got that name. Jimmy, Jimmy Moore, Jimmy, Jimmy Moore.
I love that song. Anyways, thank you, Jimmy. You are another enduring part of Britney Spears legacy.
You are going to be our pilot, our guide for this episode. If you can't support the Patreon, that's fine, too.
Just help get the word out about the show. That really, really helps out a lot.
We also have a merch store. It's in the show notes and
if you're supporting the Patreon and I haven't gotten your address yet for the stickers, send me your address over.
Because we're starting to mail those stickers out and they're really, really cool. Now, Jimmy,
I'm going to toss you the keys to the Jason Jalopy, but just keep it idling right now. Outdoors, not, we're not in the garage.
Something weird is going on. Something weird is going on. This is what I meant by saying we have a problem, guys.
So every day I wake up and I go to
about five different news websites. I go, quote-unquote, "news websites."
I go to Fox News, CNN, Drudge Report. That's where I get my mainstream news at.
And
Drudge Report always has some weird tabloid headlines and stuff like that.
So I got that and then I'll go to the export and I'll go to Reddit. Between all of those combined, I usually get
about four to eight leads. I may not fully investigate any of those stories.
There may be a story that's so intriguing I'm recording that day.
You can go either way. What's super weird is in the past five or six days
I have gotten in almost no new stories at all across all those formats at all.
The last story I got actually was from Reddit. We're gonna cover it Friday. It's a mind-blower.
I never ever ever heard of this story before. It's absolutely jaw-droppingly nuts. Almost got no engagement on Reddit.
Vito, Vito
Scoletta sent me a story last night.
I don't think I'm gonna do a full story on it, but I wanted to give him a mention because it's fairly interesting.
I guess the video this was on the export. The video game Carneval
was created by... It was interesting because it started off really interesting and then like a lot of this stuff does.
The mythology starts tripping up the myth. Originally the video game was supposed to have this deleted level
that was considered too obscene. When Midway was looking at it, it was a tunnel of love theme.
Carneval is a light shooter video game where you're like, it's pretty gross, especially for its time.
It came out in the 90s. And apparently they had a tunnel of love
level that people thought probably had like S&M stuff in it. Midway goes gross. You can't do that. That's possible, right?
There's possible some programmers are joking around.
But then it gets into this thing that it's really this cult. This ancient cult was building the video game and some of the
programmers were like working for the cult and one of them was trying to meet one of the Sailor Moon characters.
And I checked out at that point. So thanks for the recommendation.
But other than the story we're gonna talk about Friday, which I'm not gonna give away and
the carnival story. Oh, oh, and some guys also saying he's made telepathic communication with a cute alien.
I mean that that's all I've gotten in the past four or five days. I'm not covering that story, right?
It's almost sea and you could say it's the news cycle. You go Jason, things are really turbulent right now.
No, that's not it. I've been doing research like this for years and years and years and I've never run into a drought like this.
I mean obviously it could be that I'm getting more picky, but I'm not even getting stuff to be picky about.
Carnival, cute alien telepathic girl and the Friday story, which I'm probably hyping up at this point, but I mean it's super bizarre.
And it's real. It's one of those stories that worked its way through the legal system and the court system and stuff like that.
It involves all sorts of stuff. Space and conspiracy and truth, right?
It almost... I don't know man. I don't know. I'm not a conspiracy theorist.
It almost... I don't know man. It feels like maybe the veils tightening. Maybe they... and hopefully I'm wrong.
Hopefully we just aren't some weird dry spell, but what if the world is getting less weird?
It'd be a very dull place if across five websites that I normally get four to eight weird stories
I'm finding nothing except two people arping on the export and then this
story that happened back in the 80s. The weird story again happened in the past back in the 80s.
So who knows, but it is something we're gonna keep an eye on. Okay, so you got that car warmed up, Jimmy.
We are driving out from Hood River, Oregon. Burp, burp. We are headed to...
Oh, Oregon. I forgot we're going to Oregon. We're leaving Hood River, Oregon. We are headed to
Forest Grove, Oregon.
So it's the early 1900s, Forest Grove, Oregon. And there we're gonna meet an unnamed dude.
I know, I just heard your eyes roll. My eyes rolled as well. We just heard we are gonna meet this big giant
unnamed dude.
We're gonna name him Barry. He's just big strapping man. He's an outdoorsman.
So of course you're gonna be strapping and he like does like chops down trees and stuff like that.
That's not his job. He's actually an accountant. That's what he does on the weekend.
He chops down trees, but he's most known not for being a big burly guy because that's pretty much a lot of woodsmen.
It is, he's known for having a big brass bugle.
He always carried around with him in the middle of the woods.
Which you know, could be like a romantic thing, you know, like a guy up alone in the woods, his dog sitting next to him.
You're like out and you see like a little silhouette on the mountain side.
You see a little dog and you see a guy, a mournful soul with his bugle.
And you're like stoking the campfire and stuff like that.
That's not what he did. That's not what this guy did. That would be fine, right? That would be slightly romantic.
But he wouldn't do that.
He may have done that after work as the accountant. What he was known for, what this guy was known for, is you would be in the woods, okay?
You would be in the woods. You're hunting. You're fishing. You're enjoying the solitude of
nature. This is so funny. I love this guy.
Except for what he does later. He would enjoy the solitude of nature. You go out to woods to find some peace.
This dude would creep up behind, this guy would creep up behind you with his big bugle.
Get as close as he could and go "BURR" and totally freak you out, right?
You've been in the woods. You've been alone for like two hours at this point. Just a little fishing rod.
Shhhhhh.
Shhhh.
And then "BURR"
I'm moving away from the mic to do that sound effect. He wasn't. He was getting as close as possible
to blow a giant bugle right in your ear. So people in town HATED his guts.
They absolutely hated him.
So when he was found murdered, or more specifically when he was found killed
later on, I don't think there was a really big obituary written for this guy.
Assuming he's real. Now again, before I finish the story,
we're gonna put our skeptic cats on because we're gonna take it off in a second. This story,
this is a local legend. The fact that we don't have an exact time period or the name of the guy makes it very suspicious.
This guy may have never existed, but in Forrest Grove, this is a local legend. People do believe this is real,
while others may just poo poo the whole thing. Burn that skeptic cat because now we're gonna get into the fun stuff.
So anyways, this dude's body is found dead. Now the story is that
they find him and next to him they find a
dead mountain lion. And this dude was totally like all gashed up and stuff. "Ah no, the dramatic reenactment.
No, my face. Oh no, not my arm. Oh no, my other arm."
And he's getting eaten up by this dude, this mountain lion, but at the same time he's using this brass bugle.
It's so heavy. He's just bashing in this mountain lion's skull.
So they basically both kill each other in their blood pools together into one big puddle. And that's the end.
I mean, that's that's interesting, right? A practical Joker getting killed by a mountain lion.
Maybe he tried surprising him. Maybe the hunter became the hunted.
But what makes this story unique is that it is one of the very few times
that a ghost kills a person.
Whaaat? You haven't even gotten to the ghost part yet. So what happens is they start finding people in the woods
with their heads bashed in. What? What's going on? The detective comes out there. He's shining. They don't have flashlights.
The detective comes out there. He's holding a candle. He's dropping wax all over the crime scene.
He's covering up all the fingerprints.
It appears that this man has had his face caved in. And according to all my experience being a forensic scientist and a band leader,
I can tell that this injury, this injury is caused by a large brass bugle.
Does anyone in town know anyone who has a large brass bugle? What? Well, Barry used to. Well, let's get him.
Uh, Barry's been dead for two years, Detective.
You like that? Theater of the Mind, folks! Bet you pictured that perfectly.
People are starting to get found in the woods with their heads bashed in with the bugle. Now,
it's funny. I was telling Sabine this story and I was like, yeah, and this ghost killed a bunch of people and she's like,
oh, okay. I was like, that's super rare. It's incredibly rare
to come across a story where a ghost is killing people. In my experience, like off the top of my head,
I know of two. And I've been researching this stuff for decades.
Two actual ghost killing people. We've had stories of like Freddy Kruger is based on a demon in Hmong culture.
That's a demon. We've had stories about, um,
actually have an upcoming story about a village that was getting killed by a spirit,
but that was like a haunting curse. As far as a human dying and the ghost coming back and killing people,
extremely rare. I, off the top of my head, I can think of two. Lucky Boy Mine, which we covered that a long time ago.
We just did a repeat of that. And this story is very, very rare.
And it's funny because Sabine was surprised because in the movies, it's super common. A ghost is killing people.
That's the movies, guys. That's fake. In real life, in real ghost life,
it's extremely rare. Extremely rare. So one, that makes me think that this guy was not killed by a mountain lion.
If he existed, let's again, assume he just existed. Somebody got bugled by this dude, right? Just burp, right in his ear,
and then killed him. And then, maybe he already had a dead mountain lion in the back seat of his car,
and he's like, "Ugh, they didn't have cars." Maybe he had a back in the back seat of his horse.
Throws a dead mountain lion on top of Barry, our bugler. Who knows?
I mean, okay, that's a little, that's a little harder to pull off. He kills a man. He's like,
"And now I must hunt a mountain lion to have the perfect crime." He spends the next four days in there trying to track down a mountain lion.
But it doesn't make sense why a man would get killed by a mountain lion. A man who wasn't murdering people in the first place, okay?
He was a normal jerk. He basically would have a YouTube channel with two million subscribers if he did this today.
And he was a normal guy, and then he gets killed by a mountain lion, and then he begins murdering people.
Like, that, first off, ghost murdering people is extremely rare. But then, to have just, I just think it's, that's weird enough, but then
To not be a revenge-seeking ghost. The Lucky Boy Mine was a revenge-seeking ghost.
There, there, odd story. The reason why people think that the bugler was doing this was that
some guy almost got his head caved in, and he turns around, and as he sees the bugle coming towards his head,
he turns around and sees a ghastly glowing outline of a man whose face was all gashed up.
And he's swinging the bugle, and the guy jumped out of the way. And then he went to town and said,
"This dude who, who may or may not be fictional, honestly, but this dude tried killing me with a bugle, and his face was all gross."
And people go, "Oh, we know who that is. There's only one gross guy
who ever played with a bugle, and that was Barry." So, an exceptional story because we have a ghost murdering people.
It's super, super, super, and you could go, "Jason, well, you're cherry picking. Maybe the ghost demon."
Even, even if we included demons killing people, we're still looking at maybe
a dozen of like a ghost, of a non-caporial ghost. Not a possessed person, but a non-caporial ghost or a demon
killing someone, not making them kill themselves, actually killing them. We're looking at maybe a dozen stories.
It's incredibly, incredibly rare. So, basically, more of the story is, don't go to Forest Grove, Oregon.
Apparently, their sky is making weird sounds. Their ghosts can do the impossible. People still think this guy's out there.
This guy's still out there playing that lonely bugle. I'm actually thinking about
visiting some of these haunted places in Oregon. If you guys know how much I despise
traveling, you guys would be like, "Oh, I'd go there all the time. I don't like going any place I can't walk back home from."
So, anyways, I may go to Forest Grove, or I may just stand the camera crew down there and I'll watch them.
I'll watch them like Obama was watching Osama bin Laden being killed. I'm just watching on cam. I'm like,
"Good job, guys." They're just like walking through spooky forests and I'm eating popcorn. I'm watching them just getting killed with bugles and I'm like,
"Too spooky. I'm so glad I'm not there. So glad I sent out my B team." Not the fans that I really love.
Jimmy Moore light up that carbonic copter. We're leaving behind Forest Grove, Oregon. I want you to fly us all the way out to Brazil.
Flying over the Pacific Ocean. We're headed out to that emerald
country. I don't know. The country with a bunch of trees. That's the only country with a bunch of trees.
We're flying out there. Now, most of this information, really all of it,
I got from a very well-written post on
Above Top Secret is a website.
It was written by someone named Fro Charroca.
Fro Charroca. So I want to give a tip of the hat to that, a tip of the space helmet to you.
Thank you so much for doing all this research. Now, I did find a couple other mentions of this. It wasn't a fictional story,
but for the most part because of the age of the story and because of the language barrier,
you don't find a lot of stuff. Like when people send me stuff from Mexico and Brazil,
I really love to read it or really any country. I get stuff.
But I was getting a lot of stuff from Fabio from Italy.
There is that language barrier. It makes it a little bit harder.
And actually, I can run a translate on it.
Just there's not a lot of resources on it to begin with. It hasn't really got into the paranormal world.
We're going to go out to the Serra Pucatote Mountain.
Everything used to be sepia tone and now it's all lush green jungles and stuff like that.
But this story still takes place fairly recently
in the past 100, 150 years. So this story takes place an old time in Brazil.
There's a tribe known as the Ben-Gochre tribe. So they're walking around and stuff. They can do other stuff.
They can also sit and sleep, but there are no Matic tribe. So they go where the food goes.
So they got their arrows and they're looking and they see like this gazelle standing there and they go to shoot in and moves.
And then they go shoot in and moves again. They go to shoot it and it moves again.
And they say they know they're 400 miles away and they finally kill it.
And they're like, all right, where do we cook it at? And they're like, oh man, we left the fire.
We left the fire all the way back there. So they got to set up a new fire.
And then the next day they see Brazil walking, they're like, this time
we're going to kill it right here. And then they end up in another country.
They end up camping near this Sarah Pucatote mountain in Brazil. So they're sitting there.
They're eating their gazelle, which I don't actually even think exist in Brazil, right?
They're eating a taper or something, right? Originally they were hunting a gazelle in Africa
and then they chased it across the ocean. It's all swimming. They're swimming after it.
They end up in Brazil. So they're eating a taper. They're eating a big old bow constrictor,
whatever's down there. And they see mist all around the mountain. And you're like, Jason,
that's pretty normal. But this was cursed mist. See, at this mountain, they would often see like
weird lights and like the mist seemed especially cursed. They're like, don't go to the mountain.
That mountain's spooky. Like we can hang out down here. We can eat all the animals we want.
Don't go to the mountain. But they are camping near the mountain. They see the mist.
And then one time they see a light fly out of the dark night sky through the mist and then
crash somewhere near the foot of the mountain. So they go, we better go investigate that tomorrow
morning, right? Like let's not go. Let's not rush to go out there right now. What they used to describe
it as was a flying canoe. So the next morning they get the warriors and they wake up. They get the
actual street gang, the warriors. They fly them out from New York City. They get the warriors of
the tribe and they're like, wake up, wake up. You got to go check out that big old flying canoe.
And they're like, oh yeah, I forgot about that. The warrior is hoping everyone else forgot about it
because he's super scared. He's like, oh yeah, I'm already sure it's nothing. I think I saw that last
week. It's no big deal. They have it all the time. Anyway, the warriors, the super scared warriors
go out to where it's at and they see a man, not a man, a humanoid thing kind of walking around
where the canoe had crashed. And they're like, oh, that's weird. They see this guy walking around,
right? And he's like big and puffy. He's like a big puffy dude walking around and he turns and he
looks at the warriors and he has just one giant eyeball on his face. The warriors kind of, ah,
first they just thought he was like a puffy albino dude, but now they realize he's an alien.
So they start shooting arrows at him. That's their first instinct because this is an outsider,
this is an invader. And the guy doesn't even flinch. Arrows are just going point,
point, point, point, bouncing off of them. One eye just staring at him. And then the dude,
this alien guy has this big old stick and he points it at a rock and the rock disappears.
So the warriors can't look at each other at this point. Now they can't run away.
This is the reason they exist. They have to protect their tribe. They've been training their entire
life for combat. They get another volley of arrows. They're shooting arrows. Plink, plink,
plink, plink, shoot him in the eye, shoot him in the eye. Someone says, "Plink, plink,
doesn't matter." He points the staff at a tree. Poof! Tree disintegrates. One of the warrior pulls
out his club, runs up and starts beating the guy, beating the alien up. Alien just shrugs the
dude off. He points his wand at one of the tribe members. He passes out, just falls to the ground.
He points at another one. Arrows are still bouncing off this dude. Bink, bink, bink, bink. He points
another one. That guy passes out too. At this point the warriors are like, "Okay, I need to get a new
profession. I wonder if I can still get into that hunter-gatherer thing I've been hearing about."
They grab their fallen comrades. They take off into the jungle and they look behind and they see
this one-eyed monster just kind of standing there. Not that one-eyed monster. Don't be perverted.
They see it standing there. And from that time on people are like, "Okay, remember how we said
like the mountain was cursed and all that like mist and stuff? It's 100% cursed now. There's a one-eyed
monster there that he's shooting you with stuff. Again, don't be dirty. He's shooting you with stuff
and he's making you fall asleep and just stay away from that mountain." And one's like, "What?"
So people just kind of avoided that area. And since it's a nomadic tribe, it wasn't a huge issue.
They're still kind of moving around the area. A couple years later some people are hanging out.
They go to the like Laundromat, aka the lake to do their laundry. And someone sees this giant dude
just skinny dipping. And they're like, "What?" And then they stand there and they watched for a
while. And then like 20 minutes later they're still watching. And someone's like, "Hey, Onako,
are you done doing the laundry yet?" And she's like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, almost. I'm almost there."
She's still watching this guy just swim around naked. And then after she's gotten a good eye
full or two, she goes back to village. She's smoking a cigarette. She goes, "You guys won't believe what
I saw. There's this giant naked dude skinny dipping and all the girls are like, "Oh, the
Chawman's like, "No, no, no, you crazy girls. Let's send the warriors out." And the warriors are like,
"Yeah, we want to see it too." So anyways, the warriors go out and there's this giant naked guy
swimming in this lake. And he turns around and he goes, "Hey, hey guys, how you doing?"
And he's speaking their language. And they're like, "What? How'd you know that? How'd you know
speak a language?" And he goes, "I know a lot about you guys. You guys might not recognize me,
because I'm this giant tall albino looking dude, but you guys shot a bunch of arrows at me a couple
years ago." And they're like, "What? No, that was a one-eyed monster that we were shooting and stuff
at." And he's like, "You mean that?" And he points over, "You guys might have picked up on this to
begin with his space suit, his astronaut space suit." He says his name is Bepp Karoti. And in that
language of that tribe, it means "starborn" or "man of the stars." And he goes, "Listen, I know we got
off to a bad start. I paralyzed a couple of you guys and I destroyed that rock." And some guys
like, "That was my favorite rock. I'm sorry, man. I know it was your favorite rock, but I was trying
to show you guys how powerful it was. We got off to a bad start, but I'm kind of bored and lonely.
You see, I'm not going to be able to leave for a while. I'm stuck here on your planet. Can I hang
out with you guys?" So they invite him into the tribe. I mean, what are you... The other option
is they say no, and he's like, "Then I'll destroy you all." I mean, like, you're going to invite him
into your tribe, right? He's a super powerful monster man who paralyzed your greatest warriors.
You're really not going to tell him no. So he comes to the tribe. He starts hanging out. Now,
we have this weird classic tale where he's hanging out of the tribe and there's like a young maiden
watching him. He has clothes on at this point. I'm assuming. I don't think he was naked the whole
time. There's this young maiden kind of checking him out. And he's sitting there and he's eating
dinner. And he's like, "Oh, this is really good." And she's like waiting him. She's like giving him
little, like, dough-eyed eye-look things and stuff like that. You can obviously tell I'm a romantic
at heart. And then there's like a scene where there's like a full moon and there's bugle music playing
in the distance. And he's like, "I've loved you ever since I came to your planet." And she's like,
and she's like starting to swoon. And then we cut to "Take Your Breath Away," musical montage of them
banging in a hut. And then they're married. He ends up, the long story short is he ends up marrying
this native girl. And she gives birth to two kids of his, a boy and a girl. And then he's there long
enough to not only have made a peace treaty with the locals, but being a woman, raise two kids,
and become a grandpa. His daughter has a kid. So they've been chilling here for a while. And his
daughter's name was Cobb. So I mean, that's just a weird name. Maybe it's a normal name in that
community, but I don't think so. I don't, it could be wrong. I could, that could be the most racist
thing I've ever said on the show. They're like, "What? President of Brazil? His name is Cobb,
you racist? I'm pretty sure it's a space alien name." Again, could be wrong, but the fact that her
dad was a space alien, I think I'm fine on saying that Cobb is a space alien name. Anyways,
while he's raising this family, he also starts teaching them to not be nomads anymore. They're
like, "Go to hunt the gazelle." And he's like, "No, no, no. Not only is that animal not indigenous
to this continent, but you don't have to do that anymore. I'm going to show you how you can build
a civilization in one place. And I'm going to make your weapons better. I'm going to train your warriors
to be better." And then there's a montage of him like training the warriors. They're like punching
sides of gazelle flesh. They invent stairs and then they're running up them. And, and Beth is sitting
there with his little timer. Click. Yeah, good job. Good job. It's a sundial. They have to run until
it goes from 1 to 2 p.m. Everyone's training. He teaches them how to build a better society. And
then, so everything's going great. He's met the love of his life. He's having kids. He's training
these people to become much better fighters. He's training them to become a more cohesive
civilization. So one day, everything's going great, right? He's building up their society. He has
grandkids for crying out loud. One day he goes out on a hunt. He's showing the hunters how to do
this stuff. He's like, "This is how you do it. You don't have to track them across two continents.
You can do this." Arrow goes right through the taper's neck.
Great job, Beth. Thanks for showing us that. Beth? Beth? Beth is gone. Where did he go? I don't
know. Where'd he go? The hunters get back to the village and everyone in the village is like,
"Get ready. We think something bad's going to happen." And what happened? Well,
Beth came back here and he painted his family black. So that's just weird. That's just weird,
right? That's very, very uncommon that someone's going to come back, paint their family any color,
really, and be having a good day. But he paints them black and he locks them in the hut. And as
they're telling the hunters this, they notice Beth, he's walking out from behind the hut,
wearing his astronaut suit, which everyone in town knows full well is arrow proof and spear proof
and club proof. And he walks into the center of the village and he starts going, "Okay, guys,
who's going to fight me? I am taking control of this village unless one of you guys stops me."
Or like, "You're a space alien who's indestructible and you have magical powers. We're not going to
fight." Because no one will fight him, he starts upsetting the forest on fire. He's like, "Okay,
who's going to fight me? Who's going to fight me?" And people are like, "Bep, no one's going to fight
you, right?" First off, there's a raging forest fire behind you and I'm pretty sure your family's
in a thatched hut. So not a great planning on that one. But secondly, bro, we're not going to fight
you. What's going on?" And Beth says, "That's it. That's it. I'm out of here." And he walks out of the
village, flaming forest fire, leaving his family painted black in the hut. He walks out of the
village and they watch him. I don't know how they saw this part. This is not part, I mean,
unless Inspector Gadget has his telescope of guys, they watch him walk all the way to the mountain.
And at that point, a beam, booooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
And at that point, a beam, booooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
They're like, "What just happened?" She's like, "I don't know why my dad did that, but I do know this."
He'll always be in here. She taps her head. Because I've been in contact, I'm in telepathic
contact with him. And if we ever need our help again, he'll come back. Fast forward years later,
crops aren't doing too well. All of the structure that Beth had set up starts to fall apart. Crops
aren't doing well. Famine hits, disease hits. The village is dying off. And one day, and the
daughter's watching all this happen and everyone's getting sick and she goes, "Now's the time."
In our darkest hour, she paints herself and her kid and her husband black. She prays to her father.
The light canoe comes back. He comes back down, goes, "What? What? You guys have totally messed
this stuff up. I told you to irrigate, irrigate, irrigate. What's this?" He replants all their
crops, gives them new crops, gives them crops that were not indigenous to the area at all.
He shows them how to build stone houses, which technically you should have shown him how to do
that the first time. He actually tells them to get closer to the mountain. This should be your home,
closer to the mountain. This mountain will help protect you. And they changed the name of the
tribe at that point to the Kayapo. And to this day, they have celebrations where the people in the
village have a bamboo suit that they wear and they dance around in as their celebration to Beth.
Now, what's interesting, when you look at the photos of this guy, the first thing you think of,
that looks like an astronaut suit. In the 1970s, you had some kids that had come from those tribes
into other big cities. This tribe still exists. It's not one of those completely isolated tribes.
And this story I told you about, this is when I said "Old Time Brazil," we're not talking
1400s, 1200s, 600s Brazil. We're talking like 1700, 1800s Brazil. There was a time period,
fairly recently, that the story took place. This isn't a creation myth. The conquistadors had already
been there. This tribe was already interacting with other nations. But they're just like, "Nope,
we don't want any part of that." And they were moving around Brazil. This wasn't an ancient,
ancient myth. So you have people still doing the ceremony at Beth. And when you have these kids
do a cultural exchange, they went to a big city and they're seeing footage and seeing photos of US
astronauts landed on the moon, they go, "That is what Bep Karate looked like." That is, that's exactly
what he looked like. That was the description. That one eye is basically the giant glass advisor.
Which is how you, if you're calling stuff flying canoes, if you saw an astronaut turn around and
look at you, it would look like a giant eyeball. So that's the story of Bep Karate. It definitely could
be, we got to run through these always, it could be fiction, it could be 100% fiction made up
that's leaked onto the internet and has become this story. It's definitely possible too. It could be
made up at the time. It could be a legend that was made up by the tribe to explain certain
things. Someone's like, "Where'd you get those beet seeds at?" And he's like, "Oh, let me tell you a
story. Let me tell you a really long complicated story about an alien coming down and having kids
and stuff like that." The person who originally made the story popular before it got to a
above top secret was Hawa Ameriko Arett. He was a researcher who worked with native tribes and
he was with the tribe like in the 70s. So even if it was 100 years from when he, even if their
timeline was accurate, we're talking 1800s. I'm giving them a little bit of wiggle room, but that
means that that genetic line, Bep's kid, if he had a daughter and the daughter had a son,
and that was only 100 years ago, 150 years ago maybe, you know, give or take some years,
and that was happening, that genetic line should still exist in that group of people. There should
still be someone who were now maybe five generations removed, six generations removed from this story.
We should still be able to find a spark of genetic information of this star man. But the thing is
this story is so obscure nobody really knows about it. If this story was more popular, you know
that History Channel or Gaia or whatever would send someone out there to start testing these
people's DNA to see if they could find the star child. Nobody knows about this story. I think
it'd be really interesting and I think people in that community would want to know, because it would
prove their story that their culture is based around. So yeah, if you work for one of those
companies, why not? If you work for one of those companies and you're listening to my podcast,
let's do this. We can actually, again, with their permission, I'm not saying that we need to take
their blood against their permission, but with their permission, let's find, we can prove if this
is real. If this is real. If there really was a man from the stars who slept with a woman and had
kids and grandkids, and most likely it went on from there, and then came back again to give
him more fruits and vegetables and stuff like that. Maybe, you know, dropped off a couple of
gazelle. Those gazelle they'd been hunting all along, Bepp dropped some off from their ship.
So if you're ever driving through the middle of nowhere and you happen to see a spaceship crash
in the distance, you will want to check it out. I think we all would want to check it out. I would
check it out via webcam. But if you drive off towards the crash site to see if there really is a
crash ship there, just make sure that you're not traveling with any attractive women, or if you
are an attractive woman yourself, just be prepared. Because the alien that crashed on the ship may
not just be an indestructible warrior. He may also be a man looking for the love of his life.
I mean, ladies, could you could you do worse than an alien? Who can make stuff disappear?
But guys, be careful, because you're hunting with your girl and she sees this giant naked
dude walking around. No matter how much you swing your club, it doesn't work. This other guy just
get bounces off this other dude. Don't blame me when she leaves you. I'm telling you right now,
if you if you want to keep your girlfriend, don't go towards the crash UFO. But if you're a girl
and you're looking for love, you should just keep heading out to that crash site till you approach
the radioactive debris. Now that's not dangerous. That's just the glow of romance.
DeadRabbitRadio.com is going to be our email address. You can also hit us up at facebook.com/DeadRabbitRadio.
Twitter is @DeadRabbitRadio. And DeadRabbitRadio is the daily paranormal conspiracy and true
crime podcast. You don't have to listen to it every day, but I'm glad you listened to it today.
Have a great one, guys.
(upbeat music)
[MUSIC]